yeah Eric Church has taking shots at
fellow country star Garth Brooks after
Garth was named Entertainer of the Year
at this year's CMA Awards first let's
recap what's been going on the past week
all right so you may remember that Garth
beat out Eric along with Carrie
Underwood Keith Urban and Chris
Stapleton to be named Entertainer of the
Year for the seventh times setting the
record for the most wins in the show's
history and his third time winning in
just four years but it was all abuzz
about who didn't win that caused a
little bit of upset with many fans
thinking that a fresh face like Eric or
Carrie should have taken home that
prestigious prize and it seems as though
Chief three continuing his double down
tour in Washington DC on Saturday night
Eric performed a cover of Waylon
Jennings 1975 classic are you sure Hank
done it this way which is one of the
most recognized protest anthems in
country music so during the sold-out
show he used the opportunity to switch
up the lyrics a little to throw shade at
Garth Brooks because really how else
would a country singer crochet in the
final verse the sana lyrics go like this
singing my songs and one of his now and
then but I don't think Hank done him
this way no I don't think Aang done him
this way but Eric put his own spin on
the classic changing the line to around
and I know Carr didn't do it this way
[Music]
clearly the crowd loved it and even Eric
couldn't help but hold back his own
laughter as for Carswell he was a little
busy performing in front of his sold-out
Stadium in Knoxville Tennessee that
night so there was really no comment
yeah but this isn't the first time that
the singer has called out Garth Brooks
back in 2017 the chief had some thoughts
after Garth took home Entertainer of the
Year after lip-syncing at the CMA Awards
telling Rolling Stone so the winner of
the biggest category of the night
lip-sync in the biggest moment of the
show but what do you think was this all
an innocent joke or was he really
intending to slam Garth who do you think
deserves to win an entertainment here
you can comment on all of that let us
know in the comments section below